es uno de los puntos de escape más
concurridos la ciudad de Puerto Sudán es
una urbe ubicada en los márgenes del mar
Rojo frente al reino de Arabia Saudita
Este es el destino de miles de sudaneses
que huyen de los combates entre
facciones militares en su país los
enfrentamientos han dejado como saldo al
menos 550 fallecidos y casi 5000 heridos
el caos y la desorganización es visible
en este punto de salida
como pueden ver en las filas hay mucha
lucha hay gente que lleva aquí dos tres
cuatro días y se quedan a dormir en las
calles cuando llega un barco sellan sus
pasaportes y se van estamos luchando
mucho y hay dificultades en el proceso
de evacuación las condiciones en el
sitio no son idóneas para albergar al
número de personas que llegan incluso
algunos comerciantes abusan cobran las
habitaciones a 100 dólares por noche
podemos ver lo que está pasando una
crisis de hacinamiento y no hay señales
de que alguien esté presentando una
solución para toda la gente atrapada
Aquí no hay credibilidad
más al norte en territorio egipcio los
udaneses se reflexionan con la calma que
supone estar a salvo la situación que
dejaron atrás
cuando nos fuimos vimos la destrucción
es destrucción para el pueblo sudanés
alabado sea Dios cada vez tirados en las
calles algo muy difícil de verdad por
Egipto han transitado unas 50.000
personas en busca de protección tan solo
el jueves Arabia Saudita cogió a 1700 se
refugiados en Sudán quedan los intentos
sin éxito de lograr un cese de las
hostilidades entre el ejército comandado
por el general
y los paramilitares de la fuerza de
acción rápida dirigidos por Mohamed